amici siccome voglio portare un po più
di qualità sul canale ho comprato non
avere un marco mi ha dato
me l'ha presa come l'apprezzato marco è
che ce l'aveva in casa e io non sono
tirchi io non ho comprato giochiamo con
l'htc paio di marco che mi ha prestato
l'utero io per un sacco di tempo
lecco quindi ragazzi come primo gioco
del wu'er del weill di questa cosa
incredibile tipo seward alto online non
poteva che non essere un classico del
mio canale che è the forest dove un
miliardo di distrarli carini dove un
miliardo di ore di gioco single player
new game e andiamo in ovviamente norma
perché già ci faranno un bacio dei
golosi almeno vediamo come va a finire
la situazione ora che io non so cosa sto
andando a giocare fuori spa paura di suo
in bar ma no non so direttamente lì
l'aereo per ogni penny c'è mio figlio
ciao tesoro messa i fatti da accarezzare
come sia per l'amarone infatti
accarezzare col pugno allora sentite la
cosa che ha tanto posso anche se posso
muovermi non uscire anche dal finestrino
ok è successo qualcosa di strano sono
sopra mio figlio che lasciamo perdere
c'è un po di turbulence quindi mi metto
questa scena rovista un miliardo di
volte ma in buona e veramente orribile
timmy sei tranquillo
stiamo per morire mangia la carne
mangiata tutta
allora dimmi chi mi guarda come il
nostro si ricordi lost si vola madonna
legami comunitari e orribile mi sembra
di schiantarmi sul serio
tutto a posto timi io sto bene mi butto
un po da vomitare sul serio però salve
lasci stare mio figlio schifoso indigeno
la lasci sta a me sono qua ma come mai
sono materia
io sono mi vedo in terza persona come
cos'è successo
non ho capito sta roba eh vabbè ma come
mi vedo mi vedi terza persona fermi
tutti
la scusa mio come come gioco in terza
persona mi dispiace questa cosa memoria
ecco cielo le mie mani belle merce
signori questo action 1 giu sto male e
un braccialetto e ad alta prove low
energy it something orson press
andrò io che devo mangiare le cose tipo
questo del riso buono l'ho già mangiato
così la prima donna rega quanto è brutto
sarebbe dentro allora ragazzi the forest
propria mostra ovviamente benissimo ed è
una figata incredibile però non ho mai
giocato il board c'è una cosa talmente
figlia mi scusi perché lasciamolo
perdere la tipa andiamo avanti
sono le stomaco perfetto andiamo avanti
allora il movimento bloccato possa
andare e fare le cose come il the forest
davvero no vabbè ragazzi incredibile non
so come descrivere questa quindi posso
andare ad aprire le valigie tipo è
bellissimo
posso tirare giù gli alberi allora
questo questo qua mi devo preparare
eccetera sta cosa mi devo veramente
preparare per penn
no va bene ma sto male e l'ora di una
bella soda che non sa vedere come si
prende quindi continuo è schifoso eccola
la nova beh non ci posso credere e
quindi posso anche prendere i tronchi e
metterne di addosso a si mai è stato
così semplice trasportare posso fare
anche palestra così bene è una cosa
veramente è la prima volta che mi
immergo così tanto nella realtà virtuale
ed è veramente incredibile ragazzi giuro
che facciamo cose visto che posso fare
come si apre alimentari a quelli col
dito non è vero quindi o col dito scelgo
le cose
quindi voglio costruì la tenda faccio un
mese no sto malissimo ma incredibile che
hanno fatto a fare un applicata del
genere va bene allora non so però come
si apre il menu ecco tra l'altro quindi
io posso scegliere le cose dal menu tipo
da cellino
prendo a che posso usarlo
fighissimo l'unica roba che mi manca
quindi e provare a cacciare e vedere
come funziona
ma gli indigeni ci sono cioè the forest
è normale questo no qui ci sono le
caverne indigeni tutto no perché mi
propri prendere veramente malato e
ragazze siamo in giro nella foresta
vediamo se riesco a fare catherine serie
b mi sento bear grylls la prima cosa che
mi vendo affari nella foresta di provare
a bere
fermi tutti è riuscito anche cosa con
cui posso limonare come si fa se bambi
fermi tutti datemi un sasso qualcosa da
lanciare ragazzi alla natura deve
mangiare l'essere umano mi dispiace mi
sto sentendo uno schifo per quello che
ho fatto però devo mangiare
la cosa che passa in terza persona mi fa
veramente venire il voltastomaco
un po come questa cosa che ho appena
fatto però non l'avrei mai fatto nella
realtà solo che sei una cosa digitale
quindi l'ho fatto però nella realtà non
l'avrei mai fatta anzi scusa mia mi
dispiace non so come togliere
l'accendino
allora ragazzi ne ha provato un po di
meccaniche la cosa che vorrei provare a
in assoluto proprio non perché sono
masochista ma un pochettino lo sono
vorrei andare dentro una caverna
se riesco a trovare le caverne se dio
vuole felici sono supsi che schifo di
dio ci sono i ragni in the forest che
cosa bruttissima giuro non pensavo ci
fossero ragni in the forest
ok andiamo anche se il karma per bambi
prima va dai ragazzi cerchiamo la
caverna e vediamo se distorcendole non
ci credo l'ho trovata subito c'è per
anni ci metto anni e trovare le caverne
io nel gioco normali guardo trovata
immediatamente questa una caverna si è
così entra centrato ma è buio pesto riga
adesso sì che vedo
buongiorno c'è bisogno di capire un
attimo la faccenda qua allora io vorrei
entrare qua dentro
si può trovare qualsiasi cosa tipo
indigeni la pasqua lì sono masochista ma
volevo provare un po tutte le meccaniche
di the forest direttamente quale quindi
mi serve sospetto di mortacci list rally
potrebbe una caverna bene difficile per
iniziale bambini ottima da quello che
volevo vedere per trenta ti aspetto qui
preparare morto fallirono rispetta
smetta non vale il pezzo di schifo mi
hanno ucciso
ce n'era un altro peccato non l'avevo
fatto fuori va bene mi hanno ucciso ma
in teoria mi dovrei ancora trovare
dentro la caverna perché il suo gioco ai
due vite ciao fratello vieni qua ai
marmi tua sorella morta la sorella
quella che ho ucciso brain child senato
mi sa che è morto orco demonio se c'è un
altro ppd ammazzo velo giuda mi lascia
da mi lascia dove vi faccio di giro
bimbi di boro tv che dovete finirla
rifaresti versi non vi vedo neanche
droid la faccio malissimo però però mi
sono veramente spaventato
io li odio pipistrelli veramente non
come l'anima di detesto voglio uscire di
qua fatemi uscire basta non voglia di
giocarci era 4 giuro dov'è in uscita da
quello uscente era qua dove sono finito
noda mi sono perso
vedi che non dovevo andare avanti lo
vedi che ho fatto casini porca vacca
schifosa mi sa che questa è entrata per
un'altra caverna ancora c'è proprio
visto regolando imposti incredibile
incredibile ci sono gambe sento anche
dei rumori veramente orribili
se mi spunta qualcosa ci sono bambini
bambini morti
gesù cristo gesù via via via via via via
via via via via via via via via via
vivere di ricordi con un puledro corri
corri bambini bambini
vedo cose c'era c'è il coach è il boss
però è difficilissimo non ho voglia
andare via voglio andare via voglio
sfuggire dal suo posto vuoi fuggire sono
in un punto dove non mi può raggiungere
ci sono
spero di sì perché sono sono morto dov'è
lo zio uefa te la sei ho perso ha ucciso
un bambino e sono morto niente
porca vacca e cuore difficilissimo fare
fuori bossi mi sono lanciato la molotov
suoi piedi ho fatto fuori decisi su a
marzo bene è finito sono al menu ma
basta basta non volete toccarla
e stata una brutta esperienza come
temevo trovare ragazzi questo era è
bellissimo vedere questa the forest
ingmar e questo era solo il primo che ho
provato di giochi è fatto veramente bene
possiamo concludere il quale i brividi
e orribile stata in caverna fidatevi non
so come faccia bear bills a farlo sul
serio non viene sempre aiutato ma se vi
è piaciuta c'è un momento mi piace anche
alle risorse che come detto da
descrizione se non sapessi di schiavi
come sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
vita da ragazzi
[Musica]